thank you Nessa for giving us like you
know a month ago a perfect example of
what this actually looks like in the HSC
so this is out of this year's HSC exam
which is kind of handy because I was
like looking through previous ones this
kind of questions not that common
um but it does come up as you can see
now just have a look at it uh you can
see here
yeah yeah what it's like where does that
come from it's like a Pokemon like a
wild call has appeared okay so what you
got here let's just rewind a little bit
you've got here all right here's where
the here's what the terms actually look
like which is a version of what we did
do you see this right it's like oh okay
start with row two Chuck in another root
two underneath there for some reason
um so these are all nested all the
square root signs underneath one another
and then they give you this this is the
recursive formula right right there oh
that's not what I wanted to do sorry
this will do
there's the recursive formula and
they've said yeah don't prove that like
this is the thing you're going to use
right and then they say this now
remember I told you right I gave you
examples of this because we could do and
it's actually very good to to flex that
muscle and work it but like I would
never have come up with this like I
could have looked at 100 of these terms
and I would never thought of course this
is cosine right and this is because of
let's have a look Pi on
the first integer there would be one
right so this would be 2 to the power of
one plus one which is two so the first
one would be Pi on four and then the
next one would be Pi on eight and then
Pi on 16. I don't know anything about
those right um Pi one four and Pi on Two
And pi and four are where I I am I and
so I could never have guessed this so
thank goodness we don't have to guess it
however after you've come up with a
hypothesis what happens after this
you use induction so I didn't I don't
have to be the person who um who came up
with the idea however I'm just going to
very quickly walk you through oh it's up
this way right I'm going to quickly walk
you through how we would do this okay
some of these bits you know how to do
right so you can see this is just me
testing out the first value so there
like we said before Pi on four you get
your two times one on root two Happy
Times satisfied so far what next
yep I'm going to assume that it's true
so you can see that it's going to just
pan out I'm just doing a substitution by
the way don't fret too much to try and
keep up with the writing because it's
going to rapidly outpace you that's why
I'm doing it on the screen because I
here's one I prepared earlier but you'll
get this afterwards if you want it now
at this point here and this is something
which I want you to feel
um in control of even though I'm about
to give you an example right
um
when you first met algebra all the way
back in year seven right we would often
tell you hey here's an X here's a y and
you know do some stuff with it find out
what X and Y are right however where
algebra really started for us is you're
trying to write stuff and it's it's
awkward to write like especially when
they're long and complicated numbers so
let's let's just introduce some Pro
numerals to make it easier for us right
so what I'm going to do in here because
I know in a proof by induction I have to
write the same terms repeatedly and I'm
like that Pi on 2 to the K plus y that's
just a pain to write a lot right so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to
introduce a prenormal for that
I'm going to say let's just call that
let's give that angle a name right hey
Miss what time's the Bell
perfect yeah that's great
so so what I'm going to do is I'm
because it's cause of something it's an
angle right so that's why I'm just
calling it Alpha you can call it
whatever you want you could call it
Theta or after Ryan that's for Sean
whatever it doesn't really matter okay
but what that means is can you see
because I've got this angle I've chosen
it to be exactly that angle so how would
you restate this in terms of alpha
yeah fantastic so this is going to be
much easier to work with because I'm
just going to have to write this
repeatedly okay all right I've done the
test I've done the assume what's next
good so I just before I even start doing
anything I'm going to just write down
the thing that I've got to prove okay so
what that's going to look like is
here it is now just before we move any
further have a look at what I've done
because I have sort of skipped a line in
there this would be 2 to the K plus one
plus one so that's where the plus two
comes from yeah now again because I'm
like ah this is just a pain I'm gonna
have to write it over and over again
think carefully though in fact I am
going to ask you to write this down how
does this relate
to the alpha that I had before
very good because it's on the
denominator so because it's it's half
the size right now this is actually very
important because when you put this in
here right you see there's the half
right so because what color was I using
Orange right there's my Alpha right in
there right so I could just write that
as Alpha on two now
how's your trigonometric identities
um this is one of those things where the
HSC exams part of what makes them so
difficult is that unlike okay here we
are learning one topic we're just going
to stay in this nice little area right
by the time of the HSC exam in theory
you know everything right so they can
combine in different areas of maps that
maybe you didn't do you didn't do
trigonometry and proof by induction at a
very simple time at all so like man that
was like seven months ago in my brain
okay that's part of what makes the HSC
so hard it's part of also what makes it
a good test of whether you really
understand because for me I can go
through a proof by induction Without
Really knowing what I'm doing it kind of
goes on auto part doesn't it you're like
oh hard algebra a bit but then off you
go right but this and this is by the way
let's have a look four marks right so
this is this is some serious work that
they're going to pay
what do I do with this half angle
[Music]
very good every halving of something is
just doubling from a different
perspective and we actually know the
double angle formula much easier right
so what I did was and again sorry for
time because I know I'm watching the
clock
um if I just go to all right this is my
double angle formula now there is a
version of this which I'm going to get
to in a second which is the it's just in
terms of cosines and the reason why I
want it just in terms of cosines is
because the question is just there's no
science at all right
um one of the tricky things for me is I
have a terrible memory so I don't
remember the formula I'm like is it the
one minus or is it the minus one like I
always get it wrong so I just remember
one thing and then you can get anything
from this result if you know it well
right so what I did was to get rid of
the sine squared I just did the
substitution there what is what does
that come from by the way that's another
identity it's got a name do you remember
they're all trig it's to do with it's
it's in a it's in a right angle triangle
so it's the Pythagorean identity if if
you want to remember where that comes
from by the way
do you remember on the unit circle
you've got sorry that's a terrible
Circle but you get the idea you've got
cos Theta sine Theta as every coordinate
on the unit circle right so therefore
you've got cos
and sine in this right angle triangle
right so this is the x coordinate that's
caused this is sine what's the
hypotenuse in the unit circle
it's one so that's where we get sine
squared plus cos squared equals 1
squared so that's why it's the
Pythagorean identity you're just doing
Pythagoras in the unit circle so anyway
that's where this comes from
eventually this is going to pan out and
give me this but I want it in terms of
the the double angle right so that's why
you can see I rearranged to here
okay now just pour through it see that
cos squared
let's go all the way back
this is a really weird piece of notation
right here sorry it's so strange can you
can you tell me what you think that
means
yeah that's right the new term is a and
plus one that's the next one right and
then that squared being there it's a bit
awkward but that whole thing is being
squared okay and this is very suspicious
to me because look the thing that I'm
swearing is a it's a cosine term right
so these are the kinds of clues that are
in your brain you're like oh am I headed
in the right direction or not okay
the bell's going to go very shortly so
let me sort of speed up a little bit
this is going to give me this right
now just very quickly I'm just going to
tell you like the reason why I'm going
towards this is because there was that
half angle that I had to deal with right
so from this line to this line can you
see I've gone from theaters to alphas
and I've just halved everything so I've
gone from a double angle thing to a half
angle thing it's just the same thing
dressed up slightly differently okay I
did a slightly sneaky thing here I took
a square root of both sides you've got
to be quite careful when you take the
square root of both sides of an equation
because if I said to you x squared
equals 25. right
what Solutions are there for X yeah you
can get both of those right but
sometimes say for example like this
might have come out of Pythagoras and we
would say oh but it's a link so
therefore I can disregard the negative
solution why can I disregard the
negative for this problem
I am listening listening to positives
not integers by the way there's there's
some square roots but that's actually
part of the the secret sorry
um have a look
how many of these numbers are going to
be negative
none of them so that's why I can
actually there's a reason why I can say
don't worry about the negatives okay all
right so now I've got this I've got to
take it away and now the actual the
proof part begins right so I can say all
right this is just like we did before we
start with the recursive definition
that's what you suggest to me Ryan it's
great because I know that this thing is
true
um I need to then sort of fiddle about
with this I I pulled the same trick that
I did before
I can say it's positive so therefore
don't worry about the plus or minus and
then from there just watch the way the
algebra kind of unfolds there's the use
of the Assumption you see that have a
look at your piece of paper that's the
that's the AK and there's the cause that
they've handed to me right and then from
there we've actually done all the hard
work
um that's where this is a bit weird I
know but let me highlight it for you
can you see I've taken out a common
factor of two which is 4 times a half
why why do I want that half down there
look back
yeah I've got this I've got this half up
here so in every proof by induction
you've got to keep an eye on where
you're going and where you've come from
right what you there's where I'm going
and this is what I've got so that's how
I sort of jam them together all right
let me just get rid of this and then we
can walk through the whole logic
together once you're once you're there
that's the half angle result we proved
up in blue and then ta-da
wow four marks
um don't worry I wouldn't have yeah
that's right I wouldn't have had a good
time but can you see you're doing like a
lot of the stands in induction stuff but
then it's like oh can I bring in my my
trigonometry that's what'll make the HSC
challenging when you get there at the
end of the year